one of your daughters likes to sing as  well right I saw a video singing she was  singing to bin platted Ben Platt yes  well he was brought as a my birthday  party this year he was brought over as a  human birthday present because now no  one knows what to get me and this year  my my friends got me human presence and  they brought one of my friends brought  lin-manuel miranda and my husband had  emailed Ben flat and said would you come  over and she sat down and locked the  bedroom door and sang him one of his  songs oh my god it was actually recently  on the show he is the night has any so  talented we've got to sing together he's  incredibly talented her edible yes I'm a  big fan and so are my daughter's yeah oh  my god so he commandeered him you got  you lock the door he's nine I will not  stop talking until you subscribe to my  youtube channel that's right and I could  talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep  still here not going anywhere I see you  don't walk away from this